welcome back to cbs morning's march is
women's history month and all month long
we've been profiling extraordinary women
making an impact on the world in our
series we're calling it changing the
game this morning we have a conversation
with the highest grossing black female
movie director in u.s box office history
what is her name ava duvernay is her
name she's a former public relations
executive who went on to direct the
oscar-winning movie selma and the tv
series when they see us now she is
amplifying the work of women in people
of color on screen and behind the scenes
jamie yuka spoke with ava duvernay and
philanthropist melinda french gates at
the los angeles non-profit e-bell which
has a mission to educate and uplift
women they met on the stage where listen
to this judy garland was discovered back
in 1934
movies you know changed my life they
allowed me to see the world outside of
my own window action for writer director
and producer ava duvernay that world
includes awards and nominations from
sundance the oscars golden globes and
british academy of film awards to name a
few
one of the things i love about you is
that you didn't pick up a camera until
you were 32 years old yes and i think
that is that's like any dog years that's
i don't know what dog is
someone told me that's old and uh yes
and filmmaker years
now approaching 50 duvernay recently
graced the cover of instyle magazine
while also balancing 14 television
projects
a lot of people are reevaluating their
lives right the great resignation you
have women that are looking going this
isn't really what i wanted to be doing
and i think you can inspire people and
go well if she could do it at 32 and and
do all you're doing
you know there's hope there the one
thing i'll say that was really uh key
for me as a woman getting into the space
was uh letting allowing it to be
progressive i didn't just quit my job
and say hey i'm here i was you know
making things on the side and so i made
four films before four full films before
i actually quit my day job the day i won
sundance i said maybe i should try this
time don't feel like you've got to do it
all at once
one motto duvernay lives by if your
dream only includes you it's too small
to that end she created a platform
called a ray crew a database to promote
the hiring of underrepresented
professionals including women and people
of color in the film and tv industries i
have the pleasure of serving on the
academy of governors the motion picture
academy that does the oscars with steven
spielberg and i told him for so long my
idea of what a director was was was him
jeans
the bomber jacket the glasses that was
the thing but can a director also have
my hair and my skin and be a girl yes
everyone can be at all and that's a big
part of our work you're opening
possibilities in their minds to the
world but even for themselves let me
hold on this for a second we read your
interview where you said you're not
getting married and you're not having
children believe that got so much
attention it's a very simple statement
but it's an important one to me okay it
is a myth that to be a whole person and
a complete woman that you have to do
these things
everyone has to decide that for
themselves when i look at our industry
and i look at the most powerful men
or the most kind of prolific men there
are women
standing next to them who actually
really support their work
and so
the day that i'll get married is the day
that i find a man who is
happy to support my work and i think the
talking about this helps us create men
create a generation of men
where that could be the norm why is it
not the norm
maybe we're going to start it right here
right now we have to rethink in society
who we are but i think media for so long
in the past told us the family structure
looks this one way
you know images are so powerful it
shifts and and shapes culture it shapes
the way we think about ourselves that's
why having different kinds of people
creating these images is imperative it's
hard to be what you can't see
and
i love that you're disrupting this
industry so that we start to see
everything
how important is it to your work to have
someone like melinda come in and
understand all of this and want to
support this and do more it's about a
shared intention a shared vision goal
mission
and you know that's why i enjoy working
with your team and you
because it's an ongoing conversation it
is a relationship um it is not a
purchase there are lessons about what
you're doing and how you're going about
trying to create diversity that will
also inform other fields and these are
our key industries media because they
tell our stories finance because power
has held their technology because it's
changing society we have to increase
women's power and influence as quickly
as we possibly can
what advice would you have for a young
woman if she comes to you and says
how do i start this what do i do where
do i go my biggest advice is begin
don't wait for permission to begin
just begin
just begin listen bravo to melinda
french gates because as you know nate
she came to us yet she said we've got
three powers
powerhouse women so we had ava duvernay
igen pooh and dr kazmikia corbin we all
sat down together to do the interviews
and ava of course i love everything
about her number one yeah her voice her
brain and her heart and how about this
if your dream only includes you it's too
small love that i love that she said you
know a director can look like me have a
hair like mine
she can be a girl um you know what i
love about the diversity in all these
different fields it serves as not just
education for the youth but a blueprint
of what the future can and should be
yeah yeah incredible ava's working on 14
different television projects i don't
know how she does it all at the same
time and she's got some big news coming
up i'll wait until she gives us
permission to share it but it's big
salute to all the super women out there